we are back with the fox news alert
communist china sending mixed messages
on president trump's kovid 19 diagnosis
while chinese president xi jinping
wishes our president and first lady a
fast recovery in a now deleted tweet the
editor-in-chief of one of china's
state-run media outlets there are no
other kind in china
mocked president trump claiming he quote
paid the price for his gamble
to play down covid 19. let's bring in
fox news senior strategic analyst and
retired four-star general
jack keane general thank you so much uh
it's pretty rich for the communist
chinese to be talking about playing down
a virus that they beset on the rest of
the world state-owned media doesn't
don't say things independently
uh what are the what is the chinese
saying and how how should we react to it
well first of all i mean there is a uh
an international protocol that's widely
accepted among leaders of the world when
one of them is having a challenge like
our president has uh they're going to
reach out with a degree of civility
and and and support for the president
and and
and his wife the first lady all that
said
it because president trump has been
unrelenting as a world leader and
identifying
i think accurately so that china
and its leader president xi led a
localized epidemic spread into a world
pandemic
because he permitted those international
flights to come out of wuhan city and
ube province
and we have held them accountable and
now there's a broad coalition of support
for that same thought process and i also
believe
it's been a catalyst for other countries
around the world pete to kind of
take a hard look at their relationship
with the chinese communist party
and reassess it in terms of what their
goals are and what their own national
interests are and that reassessment has
taken place
and that's why you see secretary pompeo
uh going around the world as
as much as he is as secretary of defense
esper as well
they are continuously talking about this
hostile nation
china and imposing its will on the world
writ large
and now i i think we're in a position
here that we've not been before
uh in in establishing a coalition and
eventually a strategy
with other world leaders in how to cope
with this reality
but general would that change in a biden
administration it doesn't seem there's
been any reassessment there he calls
them a competitor
um are they would they be greeted with a
much different world
for that to happen peter i don't get
involved in the politics of this
um the the the reality is
china wants to dominate and control
their region and they have been about
that now for about 15 years and they've
had a significant general i don't want
to get political in terms of
bullying and intimidating and as a
result of that success
they also want to get up
they also want to dominate the world and
replace the united states as a leader in
the world so
that that is not going to change
regardless of who
who is president those those are very
harsh realities we have not faced
a threat like this like since the soviet
union it's been 30 years almost
since the soviet union collapsed and we
dealt with that threat for 40 years we
are going to deal with the threat of
china
also for multiple generations
uh general we know you you speak with
the president frequently uh have you had
a chance to
to talk to him get an assessment and and
sort of a corollary to that
um what as you think in a moment like
this how do you anticipate what
adversaries may attempt to do
as they view our system uh and a
president who's at walter reed
well the president doesn't surprise me
at all in dealing with covet he's he's
vigorous
he's maintaining his duties he's got a
very strong work ethic
i'm not surprised by that at all and and
certainly
i think we all appreciate the optimism
that his doctors are telling us that
he's doing well and he and he's
improving and he's not out of the woods
yet as we all know what covert does
yes our adversaries uh certainly
our national command authority our uh
command and control our national
security apparatus that that stays
intact
it's not in crisis it's it's not
threatened by this
uh diplomatic post demand the military
is
uh deployed and operating around the
world on the same alert status
it always is and our command and control
is effective
and there's no should be no concern here
but adversaries as you mentioned pete
we'll take advantage of this
one of the things i'm convinced they'll
do because they're already doing it that
is undermine our democracy undermine the
people's trust
and confidence in it by spreading false
stories and disinformation which they've
been working on for months
leading up to the election who's doing
that china is doing it
russia and also iran and they will
probably try to change their stories a
little bit
blame the president for having covert
himself emphasize again
the united states problems associated
with covet blame the united states
for much of the problem dealing with
kovid worldwide they'll they'll use that
kind of theme
uh to create mistrust in the american
people and his confidence in our
government you know but the people see
through that they're not buying into
into that uh the reality is
we're we're kind of used to this game
that our adversaries are playing in the
information
influence business yeah uh just like
we've become unfortunately used to the
game a lot of the
press corps plays to nitpicking uh in in
what doesn't appear to be
all that uh genuine of a way general
jack keane thank you so much
for your insight this morning we
appreciate it
good talking to you